they don't know how to address an
envelope they don't know how to read
cursive they're talking about gen zero
how to read a paper map
can't get anywhere unless there's a GPS
map on their phone
all I'm saying is that gen Z takes over
the world it's got
it we're just gonna write our battle
plans in cursive on a piece of paper
that actually is a true story we talked
about it before look at her face swear
up well so there's that story where they
did the war game and the younger guys
lost to the older guys and it's because
like the older guys wrote and wrote
their plans on a note and put in a guy's
pocket and wrote it by motorcycle and
they were trying to like intercept
messages people talk about it they tell
us the specifics but Isabel then goes
into mention that uh
you were supposed to teach us yeah and
that's the most brutal thing about it
that woman she's telling a joke it's
fine it's a joke